تحدثنا خلال الحصاد عن اخبار الحروب
والنزاعات التي باتت الشغل الشاغل للجميع
واخذت العالم الى حافه الهاويه تقريبا في
كثير من الاوقات لا يقتصر الامر على الزخم
الاخباري ففي المؤشره السنويه للسلام
الخاص بمعهد الاقتصاد والسلامه الدولي تم
الحديث عن ارقام مفزعه الحقيقه فخلال عام
2022 قتل بحسب هذا المؤشر
288 الف شخص بنزاعات دوليه متعدده تصدرت
اثيوبيا المشهد بنحو مئه واربعه الاف قتيل
في النزاع بين الحكومه المركزيه واقليمي
تيجرايل بينما تسببت الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بمقتل نحو اثنين وثمانين الف شخص
المفزع بحسب المعهد ليس فقط ارتفاع الرخام
القتلى في مختلف النزاعات الدوليه وانما
ما ذكره عن عصر دموي جديد في عالمنا اذ
قال ان عدد الدول المنخرطه في النزاعات
خارج حدودها ارتفع من ثمان وخمسين دوله في
2008 الى 91 دوله خلال عام 2022
هذا العصر الدموي الجديد المحتمل كما اشار
اليه التقرير يترافق مع ارتفاعا في
الانفاق العسكري دوليا فالعام الماضي بحسب
معهد ستوكهولم الدوليه لابحاث السلام شهد
زياده بنسبه ثلاثه وسبعه اعشار بالمئه
ليصل الى اكثر من ترينليوني دولار
بتاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا طبعا شهدت
اوروبا اعلى زياده منذ 30 عاما بنسبه 13%
ترتيب الانفاق دوليا للمراتب الاولى تصدرت
فيه الولايات المتحده ثم الصين ثم روسيا
التي كانت في المركز الخامس قبل الحرب
معنى الان من مدينه اسلا في السويد
الدكتور غريغوري سليمونس الباحث المتخصص
في دراسات السلام
والنساءات
دكتور الحديث عن عصر دموي
مقبل في العالم
هل فعلا سنعيش هذا العصر
بالفعل نحن نتحدث عن عصر جديد فيه تنافسيه
اكبر ونزاعات اكثر
وما يحفز هذه النزاعات هو التحول الكبير
في النظام الجيوسياسي العالمي الذي يتحرك
بشكل سريع بعيدا عن العالم الذي تسيطر
عليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول
الغرب الى عالم متعدد الاقطاب ولا تتركز
فيه السلطه في الغرب هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه تؤدي الى بروز النزاعات في
انحاء العالم المختلفه ما اثرنا اليه قبل
قليل دكتور من انه عام 2008 وفق التقرير
الذي اشرنا اليه كان هناك 58 دوله منخرطه
في نزاعات خارج حدودها الان في 2022 يعني
العام الماضي 91 دوله
ما تفسيرك لزياده عدد الانخراط الدول في
نزاعات خارج الحدود
في الحقيقه اذا ما عايننا بعض
الارقام وبعض المعطيات في الحقيقه هناك
مصالح مختلفه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لديها خيارات لانه من المفهوم ان العالم
احادي القطب بقياده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتراجع قوته والنفوذه وبالتالي
هل تقبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
التراجع او يجب ان تتخذ التدابير لاستعاده
مكانتها منذ العام 2019 وصوله الى عام
اختارت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تكافح من اجل الحفاظ على الاحاديه القطبيه
وهذا يؤدي بالتالي الى ارتفاع نسبه
النزاعات كنتيجه لهذا القرار تعتقد دكتور
جريج وري بانه ربما المطلوب الان صياغه
اسلوب جديد في التعامل الدولي يعني قد لا
تكون الامم المتحده هي الوسيله الوحيده او
الاطار المناسب الوحيد لاداره هذه الحروب
اداره حلول هذه الحروب طبعا
انا اتفق معك
بالكامل اذا ما نظرنا الى منظومه الامم
المتحده
والصكوك الدوليه الاخرى هي تعود الى
المرحله التي انتهت فيها الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وهناك سيطره من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ودول الغربيه
الدول الاوروبيه المختلفه والولايات
المتحده لديها ثقل كبير في هذه المنظمه
والمنظمات الاخرى ولذلك تبرز الحاجه
والطلبات من قبل الدول غير الغربيه لكي
تزداد مكانه هذه الدول في
منظومه الدوليه الدول البريكس على سبيل
المثال هي مثال عن الدول تود ان ترفع
الصوت لكي تغير طريقه التعامل على المستوى
الدوري كي لا تخضع للقرارات بين لكي تشارك
في القرارات ما نراه في اوكرانيا هو خطر
للغايه على سبيل المثال في النهايه
باختصار هل هذا العصر الدموي الجديد
لا مفر منه
اعتقد نعم لا مفر منه لان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تتمتع بنفس القدره
على بسط النفوذ والتاثير في اقطار العالم
المختلفه وهناك تحدد
لمكانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
اماكن اخرى في العالم لدينا بروز الهند
ودول اخرى محايده بالاضافه الى الدول
الاوكرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور جريجوري سايمونز من
مدينه اوسلا في السويد